une semaine après la tempête qui a causé
l'annulation de nombreux vols et un
temps des fêtes cauchemardesques pour
des milliers de voyageurs se nowing n'a
toujours pas sorti la tête de l'eau
l'entreprise annoncée cette semaine sur
ses réseaux sociaux que tous ces vols
depuis Regina et saskatoune ont été
annulés jusqu'à début février son
président déclaré par communiqué que
Sunwing continuait de faire face à des
difficultés opérationnelles sans
précédent et regretter la situation mais
pour les voyageurs qui ont été coincés à
l'étranger pendant des jours ses excuses
ne suffisent pas
donc c'est certain que même si nous
offrait des billets d'avion on les
prendrait pas répondu à notre demande
d'entrevue nous nous sommes donc rendus
sur place au siège social de
l'entreprise que vous voyez derrière moi
les bureaux étaient fermés nous n'avons
donc pas pu parler à un représentant de
l'entreprise le manque de communication
de Sunwing pourrait causer beaucoup de
torts au transporteurs aérien selon des
experts dans une industrie fondée sur la
confiance des voyageurs une crise comme
celle-là pourrait être fatal pour
l'accompagner aérienne croise
spécialiste en gestion de crise
de confiance avec les passagers non
seulement la valeur de l'entreprise
baisse mais également l'adhésion des
gens et là ben il y a deux possibilités
soit les gens lâchent complètement
Sunwing puis à ce moment les ballons
devant une disparition d'entreprise soit
Sunwing qui a des ententes avec certains
hôteliers ou des choses comme ça va se
mettre sur le marché cette propriétaire
d'agence de voyage elle est plus
optimiste même si elle croit que
l'entreprise devra faire face à
d'importantes dépenses pour rapatrier
ces passagers d'autant plus qu'elle
pourrait faire l'objet de poursuites
dire je vais plus jamais voyager avec
eux parce que j'ai été bloquée quelque
part
c'est facile à dire au début mais par la
suite il faut réaliser que c'est une
situation qui aurait pu arriver à
d'autres compagnies aériennes en fin de
journée
indiqué par courriel continuez à
travailler pour régler l'arriéré des
vols et en avoir prévu 43 dont 34 ont
été complétés en date d'hier
l'entreprise affirme que la plupart
sinon tous ses clients devraient être
rentrés chez eux d'ici le 2 janvier il
semble à Williams au Canada Toronto